he's uh joe buckley play-by-play voice
for fox sports nfl baseball
and uh he's got a game this saturday
he's got the yankees and the nationals
joe kind enough to join us what kind of
hijinks did you get into when you were
growing up
i never egged anybody i felt like that
would come back on us
and bring shame upon my father so i i
didn't think that was a good thing to do
i will say that you might want to
investigate
me in this whole caper because
for some reason todd keeps texting my
wife
i don't know if you know that but todd
cannot
for some reason differentiate my number
from my wife's number
and so periodically my wife would go
that guy's texting me who is this guy i
mean i don't want to pop his bubble
do you think it's an enough president
joe no i don't okay
it's not i think he's fallen in love
with her from celebrity watch party and
her time at espn
and now i finally took matters into my
own hands and egged his house
todd you want to remember it's possible
that joe may make my house because i
have both numbers stored under joe's
name
and i guess when i'm sending it it's
going to the wrong place and i've done
this like
several times now you think i would have
gotten years figured out year
joe's been married for a while so
i don't get it but i'm not it's not that
hard do you do this to
your other guests spouses very rarely
[Laughter]
did you did you have a fan show up at
your house to meet your dad
growing up um
yeah but you know the funny thing was my
dad was so open with that
that wherever we were if we were dinner
and we hadn't seen him in two weeks and
it's like oh
dad's home we're all going to dinner and
then we'd sit down at this
italian restaurant every time canetos in
st louis and
uh somebody would come up to the table
and he would pull out a chair and go sit
on down
tell me about your life and then he got
like johnny from paducah kentucky going
well i grew up
uh in the 50s yeah so i
we they didn't need to come to our house
as my point
at the grocery store at restaurants it
didn't matter that everybody was his
friend
i'm wondering what you took away from
the broadcast last night
are you watching as a broadcaster
or or can you just watch as a fan no i'm
i'm watching these days as a broadcaster
i don't typically do that
but i think when i have tomorrow night
on the horizon and i'm going to be in a
studio in denver
smoltz is going to be in uh studio in
jersey and mlb
our producer pete macheska is going to
be in la so we're going to be all spread
out
um i watched the game last night and
matt and alex were at least together in
the studio
but you know we're spread out all over
the place and john
is is doing a bunch of games so that's
why he's at mlb
so in order to bring us together it
would have been ridiculous so we're
going to do a dry run today
we're going to see how it all works
communication wise and then
and then we'll go do it but i i was
practicing last night doing the game
off the television and uh it's a little
different seeing the ball
come kind of at you instead of watching
the ball go away which is where we
you know see it and sit during a regular
game
but also when you're you're going to
call this game and we know
we know that it's kind of crazy times
here but how long do you think you're
doing games before
you're not really acknowledging the lack
of
ambiance there at a baseball game yeah i
kind of feel and
and maybe i'm wrong i think
but i really don't want to beat that
drum too much tomorrow i mean at some
point i think this becomes a nice
distraction and something to
theoretically bring people together
and just constantly reminding everybody
of
everything that we've all been through
in our own ways over the last four
months i think people are tuning into a
game to get away from that so i
i don't nobody cares that john and uh
and i are not together nobody care you
know i think they just want to watch the
game
and and it's almost like announcer guy
okay enough shut up just let me watch
uh aaron judge uh try to get a hit off
stephen strasburg
yeah the feeling i got is give me the
tutorial if you want to give me a a once
a round to drive by and just say this is
the setup this is how it looks
and then that's it after you know i just
wanted to hear the game i didn't want to
hear
hey this is weird for us to call the
game or hey the sound or the cardboard
cutouts
we want to get away we want this we
we need this and the less i think you
dwell on i think uh
is the better approach joe i agree yeah
i mean we're doing the virtual fan thing
and
and you know obviously everybody's gonna
weigh in
uh and and some will like it or most
won't care
because it just looks like a game you
know the ones that are mad
and stomping their feet will go on
social media and stomp their feet
but i think trying to make it look and
sound this is entertainment too
look and sound as normal and as it's
always been
is kind of our job so if if we're
constantly going hey
all these people are fake or hey we're
coming back from every break and we see
cardboard [ __ ] you know
still shots and moving shots of
cardboard cutouts i
i think that defeats the purpose that's
why people are watching the ball game in
my opinion and i could i could be wrong
what about the crowd noise are you
pumping in crowd noise and to what
extent
yeah i think that's kind of a work in
progress you know they're they're doing
it in these stadiums and so
typically our ambient mics just pick up
what's in the stadium
we're not adding anything so i think if
that's sufficient
if that's sufficient then we'll go with
that but you know i was talking to our
producer and whoever these
stadiums employ to do these crowd noise
tracks
i i'm sure they don't care what it
sounds like on
tv or on fox or whatever or if they do
you know how good are they in each
stadium so if if it's not
right and it seems weird i think it's up
to us to try to make it
sound right and normal uh it can't be
a pop-up and everybody you're playing a
reaction like people are doing the wave
and standing and screaming it's
a pop-up what do you think of uh
extended playoffs here and that format
for baseball
i you know to me this was always the
opportunity to have
the test kit out there and see what
works and what doesn't
uh i i i'm excited about a 60 game
season i know schmoltz is
just kind of the immediacy of it and i i
really wanted to see even more you know
if you're ever going to bring bring a
pitch clock in and see how that goes
they're doing the runner at second base
and extra innings which i like
let's get it going let's let's find
let's get a conclusion to this thing
uh and and the same for the playoffs you
know if if
all of a sudden they have this seating
and people seem to latch onto it i just
think 2020 is its own thing
and going back to the drawing board
next offseason they've got a new
collective bargaining
agreement to put together and i think
there's a lot of things that are
potentially out there like the universal
dh i you know some people like it some
people don't
i like the two different styles of
baseball but
you know throw it against the wall in
2020 see what sticks and then move on
uh in the future got anything cool in
the office there is that your office
no i'm in a airbnb in denver colorado
i don't i'm scared to open drawers in an
airbnb i don't want to know what's in
there
i don't know whose hair is hanging out
on the floor right now it's certainly
not mine
i do not have long black hair
but there's a pile of long black hair in
the corner of my room and
it's it's whoever was here last boy
maybe troy palamalu was there
it does smell like head and shoulders
uh you're working with mklobe ultra and
uh you
you launched the hashtag ultrabuck calls
and i know that you had some fun with
this and then you know that
people would send videos and then you
would do play by play and then all of a
sudden
people sent you porn and then said do
you do play-by-play and i got an offer
then i got an offer to change directions
entirely in my career and actually
do live play-by-play for the visually
impaired that was in the contract
for webcam porn i don't know if you call
it a video just webcam porn
so yeah i i i thought about it
uh and then i asked my mom and she's
like either pick your relationship with
me or go ahead and do that
and i picked my relationship with my mom
and your dad never got that offer i'm
guessing
i don't think he did but i think a
grovely voice you know
let's take a look and see what's
happening in uh bedroom number four
i think i don't know i think the call i
don't believe
what i just saw it's gonna be uh
go crazy folks go crazy
um explain this contest you're doing
with uh michelob ultra yeah
it's kind of a take on what we did at
the beginning of the pandemic in this
shelter and place which last time i
checked had over 10 million views and it
was just play-by-play
of people doing stuff around the house
now that could be
you know cooking chicken wings on a
barbecue grill that could be playing
with the dog that could be some
ridiculous shot that could
be people on a lake messing around and
doing some trick
uh surfing or whatever i've seen it all
and uh
i put my play-by-play to it and uh
on august 1st the contest ends and then
i'll we'll put four of them back on the
internet that uh
makes people famous and something
they're showing their friends and family
for the rest of time
but so you have all the videos there
you've already done them
and then i've done some i'm gonna do
more i think
uh monday so i
it's the contest is open until august
first but i've i've seen
a lot of them uh some the bottom line is
when people clear out their
living room and make a makeshift hoop
out of an old adidas box and play
two on two hoops that's fun and and i'm
happy to do
play-by-play to that uh people are
creative
as you know we both know from what they
send in on
social media or whatever so this is just
tapping into that
what's your nfl schedule what have you
been told
so far uh you know i think that
obviously the preseason game that we had
scheduled is gone but
uh we open up with tampa bay and tom
brady at drew brees in the saints the
first weekend on a
sunday and it's a lot of brady early and
it's a lot of cowboys late and
i'm hoping like crazy that we're there
at the stadiums doing these games but
i don't know anything more than any fan
does and and i i think until we get
around to it and these guys open camp
and we see how it goes with this uh
you know it's all speculation but i
haven't heard anything to tell me i'm
not going to be there
on the first weekend of the season i'm
wondering if we have fans
at a baseball game uh before we have
fans at a football game like do you see
that nascar tested it out at bristol
motor speedway and they were able to get
what 20 000 in there but
could you see baseball as a possibility
or
or the fact that these football stadiums
are a lot of these have
a little bit more room there for these
fans yeah i i think it's all on the
board i
i would not be surprised if if the you
know the
the flattening of the curve happens it
certainly doesn't seem because of these
you know outbreaks in these hot uh hot
cities that we keep hearing about
uh in states really if if this
is really in in the near future i i
think kind of leaving it where it is
right now
and let everybody take a breath and see
where this goes is the best
idea but yeah i could see before the end
of the season
their fans socially distanced in the
ballparks
um hopefully the experience is so
unbelievable on tv that uh
yes we don't have to worry about that uh
it's great to talk to you
hope the uh the kids are good there joe
and uh yeah everybody's healthy
so uh yeah the old 6am wake-up call for
the 51 year old dad
a two-year-old twin boy what were you
thinking
what were you thinking my wife is so
tired
of of me saying you know i've already
done this
i'm too old for this i'm like riggs or
murtaugh
whichever one said that i'm getting too
old for this i am too old for this but
it's awesome it's great
but the mornings are really hard for me
and it's always if
there's a um an ability to act like you
don't hear them crying
that that you learn as a parent uh
but you know my wife would just nudge me
like it does
i heard if you know my son or daughters
were crying
it wasn't one of those uh what i didn't
hear that i just get the nudge
hey you go get them it'll be two in the
morning right so i don't know if you've
mastered that or your wife
can see right through that no she sees
her but she sleeps through
everything she she slept through me
leaving in the middle of the night to go
egg todd's house last night i didn't
even know that i left
but i i wake up at everything i if i
hear one thing
i'm wide awake so she knows yeah
todd anything else you want to say to
joe just to kind of
make anything you want me to tell
michelle
um say hi to michelle i sincerely
apologize that the way i store the
number is when i'm trying to contact you
either she's getting it or you're both
getting it but it's uh no i don't get
any of these she just flips them over to
me
screenshots for the record it was an
innocent mistake and i hope we're still
pals and
there's nothing untoward about do you
think do you think i care
do you think i really care i don't know
me well enough
your personality is such that todd you
sound guilty man
well if you check the text they're all
about joe we'd like to have you on
thursday
i don't know what well no i will say
this joe if he knew he was your wife
then it then i would have worried
because then the messages would have
been different well wasn't she watching
this cheerleader yeah i'm a big denver
bronco so i guess
well there you go there you go to
connect the dots i don't want to you
know todd incriminate myself
you just did i am a big broncos fit i'll
leave it a comment cut todd's mic off
yeah yeah yeah i will uh yeah just pan
we still have the chaps
we still have the chaps that's all i'm
going to say wow
thank you joe yeah you're welcome that's
joe buck
nationals yankees saturday night at 7
eastern on fox